dude i thought we were recording um you
look so [ __ ] up it's stuff like that
it's not bad did you you didn't go get
it looked at her well it is bad because
you're you don't you don't really go to
the doctor do you
dude dude get that mankind knee brace
back out chin's got chin's hobbled you
got a solid reference by the way i like
that mankind that mankind yeah yeah
yeah
he was all about big foley no i was
thinking about for all mankind which are
jeans that i like because they have
elastic and they fit my thick thighs oh
no that's gay no we're talking about uh
a wwe superstar yeah
he's all out of shape yeah yeah yeah he
had a mask on he was doing that
jimmy burke had an idea one time he goes
i want to do
i want to [ __ ] be a wwe wrestler and
i was like what are you talking about he
goes i'll get my buddy he had this huge
friend his friend be like you know just
this giant wrestler
he wanted to be he wanted to be strong
baby
and he would he you know i just know
here on his body is jimmy big and he's
no he's skinny like he's shredded he's
in shape and he's super [ __ ] pink
he's pink he's so weird no hair not even
eyebrows not even eyebrows and he goes
and i would walk around like a cancer
patient
and i just want to be the same that'd be
so creepy i was like it's so creepy but
so [ __ ] weird and funny i would watch
that 100 you have you have a big
personality in the wwe me yeah what
would i be though i don't know what you
would be would you
like to kill here and i would be
undertaking you'd be the paul bear
what is that what am i saying he's here
it's going down
but like you you like actually like
we could dress you up or maybe i'm just
the guy who you have me on a leash and
for no reason you like kick me something
oh thank you oh you're like he's mad and
he's taking it out on me yeah you have a
ball in your mouth and you interviews
girls
that's all i do and i haven't they have
a leather suit on
people like this is the worst wwe thing
ever
would it be hilarious i'm in a diaper
who's phone with it
you [ __ ] fired me bro
meatball you seem like a wwe fan no
no no no not at all just hockey brothers
um no we never really got into it uh guy
uh because well you guys are too young
for real well i guess oh nine how old
are you 22.
like you rock stone cold age is probably
right when you're like six seven eight
yeah yeah you're born
macho man the warrior hulk hogan those
were the days so yeah you had those days
yeah then my dad was like it's fake and
i was like i'm out that's why i didn't
really get into it i learned from you
uh just hockey football baseball yeah
just sports yeah were you drinking last
night last night yeah
you look uh look a little red look at
that
i'm hot i went to the like i'm just
really warm right now i went to the gym
for the first time in like a week niacin
or something huh take niacin oh my god
that's the trigger
i turned completely okay you know people
use that for pre-workout it's time it's
exactly how people can get you
get you looks like
and you get itchy it's a it's a
supplement people gotta write a bunch of
things all the bites
so why do people take it if you take
enough of it you look like you have a
sunburn your whole face will get bright
red it like
i mean i won't get bright but i get it
you get like maroon your eyebrow you
don't know what girl eyeballs i'm darker
than maroon no but it was the skin would
you call it i took niacin didn't know
someone's like take a bunch of this you
know you're young i'm like okay
i was like well i'm dying it's the worst
thing what do people use it for
pre-workout like there's other reason to
take it it dilates your blood vessels so
it just gives you like you just get you
just get flushed but if you do enough of
it which i did
your skin will and when i take when i
say you look like you had a sunburn i'm
not kidding you no it's just and your
skin tingles and itches like
no one really takes it anymore no we
should torture i got pierced with it i
got like water retention from it too so
my love handles i'm not even kidding the
next day the left hand was like you're
flapping over yeah
it was the worst reaction
yeah
no i don't think so no you shred it oh
dude
you love this beat you because you're
like me so last night uh we have you
know you know like when my son makes a
friend we become friends with a parent
so they're like our best friends now so
when we go on dates it's with the other
family they get a babysitter babysitter
so they set this restaurant up and it's
the salt days restaurant in uh in
beverly hills this fancy [ __ ]
restaurant we pull up bieber's there
gets all i'm like okay this thing could
be cheap anyways
anyways
we go i have a video on my uh oh yeah i
know this one i saw this that's the guy
who does this
oh yeah so so we get there and my girl
went before me with her friend she's
like it's the best steak you ever have
in my calm down shakes the best steak
you've ever had i'm like all right so i
was hungry i'm on keto now so i'm like i
can eat dinner there here's the problem
dude so the atmosphere is great good
whiskey the food is amazing
but it's it's it's like uh chuck e
cheese for adults like everything is
like what do we have here so bae and
they're like [ __ ]
like throw salt over everything and then
they're like you get an appetizer like i
got the tomato heirloom you know they're
slapping the table so like everyone's
looking and i was like man is there any
way
is there anything i can pay you not to
do can this not be a circus like it's
been
like a high level
even like more over this to the extreme
dude and i was like oh man i was like
my girl my girl knows i don't like it
she's like just be cool i'm like can you
ask the guy like not to do this stuff
and then we get carpaccio and she comes
she's slapping the table like oh my god
dude so my girl i went to the bathroom
that was funny like make sure when you
bring the tomahawk out you feed him like
with the thing and so i'm that's why
that's why if you go to my story that's
why i sit down and he's cutting up and
i'm like god i [ __ ] hate my life and
then he's like he's like straight up and
i go no i i i'm like laughing like no
get out of here dude like it's not
happening bro no i'm like he wanted what
do you do he wanted to give you a little
salt like keep going right here right
here so there he is
you're embarrassed no
i don't want the attention no
oh it's making all that noise
they through salt lake
[Applause]
he wants to feed you yeah
[Music]
it's not [ __ ] happening dude
that's all they wanted but it's like and
there's those there's those uh like
videos on worldstar like what would you
do
they're like what would you do if uh
this happened to your girl because when
salt bay is there he's like you know
he's uh turkish whatever the he'll find
like the prettiest girl who's with like
her man and they'll cut up that thomas
steak and then he'll like cut in front
of the dude and then like your girl is
basically sucking this piece of meat off
so my girl told me she was going without
me i'm like hey listen
do it
have fun i don't want you going viral
for deep throating a [ __ ] t-bone yeah
like i don't need that heat right now
yes like just if they just turn it down
right but they they didn't do anything
like that but you'll see like people
like what would you do if this was your
girl and i mean it's sexual i don't like
it
that stuff when i'm trying to eat that i
get so embarrassed when the mariachi
band comes over and starts singing yeah
when you're eating there's nothing worse
than what but it's like it's like chuck
e cheese it's like dude just the food's
like i want to be like good i wanted to
i wanted 2010 what's the food
nine and a half oh
[ __ ] the steak's ridiculous okay steaks
that go ridiculous yeah it better be i
mean by the way [ __ ] bieber's eating
the
forgotten
i mean it's great you'll you you would
love it but
like i want to talk to him i came in i
don't want all the antics just bring the
food and so everybody gets them
everybody gets the antics yeah and they
go hey and all that stuff i'm throwing
like and they go salt bae and then toss
the salt all over i'm like dude what is
happening right now
i saw it
and i want to be like is there any way i
can pay extra so i don't feel like i'm
at [ __ ] chuck e cheese yeah or red
robin so i went to a restaurant next to
it the restaurant
just passed it and oh he was yeah
it was such a scene i think it's called
i think espago yes yeah
it was such a scene i went in there and
i and i i walked by and that guy that
guy
was there he was standing right there
with sunglasses little guy he's a stud
yeah he's in shape little guy crushing
it like he has restaurants and you know
uh it's
miami new york instagram oh yeah crush
well no he was a big chef before though
but that made him super famous yeah but
they're just honestly they're doing this
picture he's just awesome he's hilarious
he's a good dude
he's 100 turkish yeah that's it but they
what they do have they have turkish
coffee you know turkish you know i like
like this drink is a nine shot
uh nine shotgun expressions
and this doesn't phase me he was like
hey it's cloudy the guy was a fan and
goes hey you like coffee or i go i can't
get enough coffee goes we have a turkish
coffee it's it's so thick it's like mud
i went bro now you speak my language
yeah i said can you bring that out and
not do like a backflip or some [ __ ] can
you just bring it out and he started
laughing and then we came i go dude can
i can i be extra not to have like all
these this [ __ ] you got like you guys
don't need to do this right like your
food is so good man right he's like it's
just that's the theme did they give you
the turkish coffee with an orange rind
or the the the orange rind was on the
side but it was just this little cup and
it's it's it's it's that's that's the
coffee the middle east all drinks that
coffee let me tell you something how
good is that should have strong thick
it's a cloud it's thick and you like i
like like i like to feel the grains yeah
and that's what like i like almost like
mud it's so [ __ ] and it comes that's
like that small like it's a little yeah
very small it's so concentrated a lot of
times a lot of times they put a couple
sugar cubes in there and i don't like
with any sugar no sweetness in my coffee
you know the only person i'm not just
saying is because they're my boys but
the only coffee that's as strong with
that that tastes like most coffee that's
that bitter or strong it tastes like
[ __ ] right the only coffee bean that can
match that is black rifle really they
have a like a black roast yeah you like
a sniper roast or the [ __ ] they call
yeah or the anti-isis roast yeah
it's so dark it's so nice i gotta have
myself i gotta have myself a dark roast
here's the problem these these we've
talked about this before but it's
there's so many coffee places where it
tastes sour it's a light bean
the light has more coffee but it's like
this new like caffeine hipster trend
yeah more caffeine and it's a lighter
bean but it's a sour coffee dude it will
ruin your [ __ ] when you get a sour
coffee it kills me the worst kill i
throw it away the worst that'll be 450
for a double espresso well you know
you know who does that now how about
just pouring some lemonade who does that
right up the street from intelligence
yeah i know they went sour and i'm like
i i can't i used to get it all the time
but they went sour i just passed it to
it you know my boy's at uh emma hotel
uh because i told him that he goes he
was man thanks for all the things you
say about the the hotel on the podcast
and he goes any uh you know any uh
advice that we can do better i want your
coffee dude like it's too sour not
everybody wants to [ __ ] with that woke
coffee get me a like
give me a dark roast yeah they have dark
roast now they do i gotta have you said
anything it was hey man we changed it
now we have two different beans that's
why i like like pete's cafe lux do you
know cafe lux come on bubba how long
have you been doing it thank you and
then you get a chocolate next door thank
you sir come on dog thank you sir
chocolate coffee and a dick suck they
they
they roast their espresso bean they're i
think it's called montenegro and they
[ __ ] like the way you say that negro
i i like that i like when the coffee
guys are all you know the only thing
about starbucks and like those those
dark roasts is they burn the beans i'm
like then guess what [ __ ] i like burnt
beans yeah how about that yeah it's
called it's called roasting it's called
good coffee roast so they call it dark
roast so they're basically burning this
[ __ ] yeah it's just that they roast it
so that you you're tasting
i like more when i drink my coffee i
like to taste i like it to taste the way
it smells yes i like it too i like
chocolate and nuts in there i will ask
this like yeah i want that i don't want
food
what is your name when i when i see
coffee and they have notes of citrus
and floral i'm out of time
nah
i'm out speaking of america though and
speaking of black rifle
is it appropriate to play
jocko willix savage
instagram there's not many people that
influenced me like him if he was like
hey brenton i need you to get on plane
right now and fly to afghanistan and run
head first at some of the taliban guys
yeah you got it yeah i talked to some
people about chocolate will it go did he
see a lot of combat and they were like
they're like oh yeah dude yeah it's the
video chin this one no he's he's a real
warrior look at this guy you ever had
his energy drink watch this no dude i
want
you grow [ __ ] eagle wings good
evening
so hold on pause it pause it let's set
this up this is him he's saying this is
what president biden should have done to
address the nation with the fuck-ups in
afghanistan he's like if i was president
this is how i would i watched this last
night it played a troll sleeper
situation in afghanistan
as you know we were set to leave
afghanistan this month and as we began
the final drawdown
i made some critical errors
ownership namely
i underestimated the strength of the
taliban
and i overestimated the strength and
capability
of the friendly afghan forces
this was my fault
and due to my mistake
the taliban has taken control of
afghanistan
there are reports now that isis and al
qaeda are working alongside them
unfortunately there are tens of
thousands of americans on the ground
there
as well as friends and allies of america
on the ground
and these people
americans and our allies are all
stranded
and that is my fault
that's right hammer's at home but they
will not be stranded for long [ __ ]
[ __ ] you guys man in the next 48 hours
friend taken
we'll be in control most major airports
in afghanistan
any resistance we meet from the taliban
or otherwise when we seize these
airports will be destroyed completely
and without mercy
from those airports we will conduct
rapid strike rescue missions until we
have recovered and evacuated all our
citizens allies and friends
any person that interferes with these
operations will be killed
we will also
recover or destroy
all aircraft vehicles weapons and
sensitive equipment that we left behind
any person utilizing guarding or located
in close proximity to these weapons or
equipment will be killed
once we have evacuated all friendly
personnel
and recovered or destroyed the weapons
and equipment left behind we will depart
afghanistan
just watching but
we will continue to monitor everything
that happens in afghanistan
through our ground and airborne
surveillance equipment
terrorist training camps or activity
will be targeted and destroyed
gross violations of human rights
will be stopped through overwhelming
force
and any group in afghanistan
fighting for freedom
liberty
and basic human rights will be supported
through special operations forces and
ruthless precision air power
we will continue that dedicated support
you can't stop returning
it though
watch hurry up
is no longer a threat to humanity or
to the good people of afghanistan
may god bless america
and may god have mercy on the souls of
our enemy because we will not
but that's how that's how it should go i
want to join the army now right now
you're young
the only the only problem with wanting
to do no problem no criticizing no the
only problem with that is that it's it's
it is a little bit like what we have
been doing so so in other words if you
were to say uh you have to support
people fighting for freedom on that side
you are choosing a side now you have
aerial bombardment now you have special
forces back in there so in a way it's
that that's that's that would be the
that would be the rebuttal right
i'm not trying to hear it from anybody
else
who's going to criticize jocko he's also
been there he's also done missions yeah
he also knows how it works we're
civilians yeah let's take it from that
cat yeah man
[ __ ] savage
does he have kids
imagine not your dad yeah that's right
your dad's captain america dude yeah
your dad is [ __ ] the real life
captain america these are rough dudes
that's four kids holy [ __ ] four kids
that's your dad we got a 10 year old
dude three daughters and uh the son of
sixteen bro there's so much pressure if
you're history oh my god you better
learn how to fire a [ __ ] gun you
better learn how to kill a man
son who's 16. one hand
what a [ __ ] beast dude dude what a
beast yeah that's your dad i had to drop
tiger out for his first day of
kindergarten today
first day kindergarten as we're driving
there look at my girl girl we're getting
old man his first day of [ __ ]
kindergarten i was talking to a tiger
because he always wants to
there's look at him with his best friend
go to the next one
that's his best buddy now that little
kid joshua yeah is a [ __ ]
freak soccer player free he plays eight
nine year olds and he's like a little
messy he's like a gift he just so his
dad played uh over in england okay so
his dad just put all the knowledge yeah
but he's obsessed with soccer so we went
to his game because we're gonna have
tiger join the team and get they have
tryouts on [ __ ] and they have like real
jerseys we go to the game and i look and
go dude your son's a freak dude he is
he's not bad he's pretty good i'm like
he's the best player out there and he's
five your school's kitchen you're either
your kid goes to because my my nephew
and my niece go there um is the best
sports in some ways in the country for
kids academics too yeah yeah really it's
gonna be good but i was telling because
he always whenever he's in a situation
he'll go dad when you were five like how
did it work for you so i was telling him
i'm like dude you have such an advantage
because
you know my dad just pulled up the
schools like all right dude
go have fun didn't know the teachers
didn't know you might i didn't have any
friends you're you know you're trying to
figure it out i'm sure same with you
like you guys got to figure it out so
the way it works is you know that's his
best friend him and joshua like they're
they're [ __ ] brothers basically
and they're in the same class it's like
do you have such an advantage you get
dropped off the first day you're not
going through it by yourself like you
have your buddy that you can depend on
go through and then they know the other
because it's nerve-wracking for kids and
then i was telling them i was like dude
you know it's a new school you know
there's new kids there so you know if
anybody's trying to pick on you whatever
you know if and they start picking on
your friend like if they pick on him
they have to deal with you vice versa
i'm talking to both of them and i'm like
breaking all this stuff down and my girl
goes who hurt you
she's like
what school did you go through i went to
roar public school and it was
hell it was like
it was war it was like taliban ran that
[ __ ] like i fought every day
and if i didn't have any cool stuff like
it was on that's how i got good at
sports is the only way i could be cool
and she's like oh my school was
traumatized i was like listen it was a
fight every day that's why i told them
like listen dude if they if you got two
around you i want you to hit the first
and my girl's like hey stop that's not
happening this school i'm like all right
i'm just trying to give him
yeah he's like dad like your first day
of school are you excited i'm like no
dude no i was terrified because i didn't
know my dad just dropped me off and i
was off the fence for myself i knew
nobody my dad didn't know the teacher
how much does your son like you is he
different than you is he's 100 like me
he is where he's my main that's why you
know everyone goes oh he's my min he's
treat me to a t myself
my son's like me and and what's funny is
that he's like you know that there was
that book the warrior the magician the
all that the lover that and he's the
magician like me
so you watch this [ __ ] kid and he's
he's bouncing he's tall he's skinny and
he just bounces he finds his way like
some of the kids are rough as [ __ ] some
of the kids are punching but he's kind
of like when when you know when you went
to school you it was you just like it's
different these days like i was like you
have such an advantage dude yeah like i
try to grind into them like
the way that that you're going through
life is completely different than what i
did like you have such an advantage
because i'm your dad and you have these
opportunities ahead of you like
my dad just dropped me off yeah and then
if i had a problem like i was getting
bullied like i had my brother you had to
deal with and then he might be kidding
me get suspended but it was like it was
rough man yeah it was and then i was
like for you because you have your best
friend with you and you know you're
familiar with other kids in your safe
environment you can focus on academics
and learning i couldn't i i was just i
had anxiety about oh [ __ ] we're gonna
get a class and then that that [ __ ]
kid's gonna bully me yeah i get on these
fake jordans like what am i gonna do for
me i cuz i was moved every year and a
half to a different country so be like
here we are
oh yeah yeah
you know i love your parents the worst
way to raise a kid well i mean it's
crazy you know my dad was always gone so
i know it would be my mom me and my
sister god bless your mom but you know
the study that they found uh the common
thing that all criminals in prison have
do you know what it is they didn't grow
up in a in the same house they moved oh
yeah yeah that would be me yeah i was
moved every year and a half and but we'd
be moved to a different country a
different school and they would throw
all the kids who spoke english into one
court of international school yeah but
then i went to french schools and then
you go to french clubs half the year
then you have to go to another so it i
didn't learn so what was the hardest way
to grow i didn't i didn't learn because
it's not like you just went from
calabasas to the west side you went from
basically the west side to afghanistan
high school so you wonder why why i
became a comedian right like i learned
how to make people laugh yeah well
that's why i got bullied so badly that's
why you know
i got bullied really badly inaudible
from my ears yeah but but you know how
my temper is bad like if if i'm if if
i'm about them i mean i'm very very long
fused but if i'm in a situation
i'm going to fight i'm going to punch
you in the face right like i get if i
think that you're remember that one time
that guy came over to the table we were
in [ __ ] calabasas thing i had one leg
out i was gonna i was gonna you know i i
i get that thing i think it's because of
that like i just go the minute i see
something like that i go if this dude's
trying to [ __ ] bully me i go back to
eighth grade yep and i go oh we're gonna
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are we're
i'm getting triggered we're going like i
was trying to explain tiger like bullies
he's like why would anybody be mean to
him like because kids are different i
said also they might come from a home
life that's not as stable as yours so
their way of lashing out is picking on
other kids yeah yeah and then he's like
oh i mean he goes i have my crew though
dad and that [ __ ] had him he
said yeah
dude he has a crew like if you don't
have a crew he's kind of different he's
like he's messing with me that mess with
everybody i'm like god damn that's
amazing so he's like
you know so he's big and strong he's
being strong but he's super not but his
problem is he's too nice well he's like
in jiu jitsu
but still like in just like dude you
guys
i know but you know boston's not like
that but you know at five it's it's all
good if he's gonna be a giant he'll
learn it yeah but he's just too friendly
i'm like i mean you're like that a
little bit you're already 100 i mean you
never would have picked on anybody you
would have been everywhere no i always
got picked on i wasn't baker's child
growing up you were not no tigers
um my first day kindergarten i was tall
i think i was taller and tired yeah and
you were always a good athlete i mean
you always had to be yeah
man it's crazy y'all were bullied
i i for me it was more chaos was it was
it just like like people were like every
day like coming at you or just am i
saying but the school i went to is
predominately black school so as a white
kid like
you were bullied but it was like it went
in waves yeah like everybody got bullied
it was like you that's just your turn
and then how are you gonna defend it and
then they go through the rest of the
kids and then it's your turn and you got
to defend it that was just a [ __ ] nut
you were yeah i didn't get bullied no
not really i mean i had people made fun
of your teeth made fun of i mean
as a kid you know i'm like that like if
he's like you're i never noticed these
teeth i don't know
the gap because it's different yeah but
i don't know i don't like character but
but you know i never i love never
drinking school i would have lit them up
that never bothered me well kids in
elementary school's teeth are so jacked
up to begin i mean yeah everyone's kids
gotta come
you know like i don't know i was like
people made fun of me for being the
black kid you know skateboarding and you
know listen to punk rock and all that
[ __ ] but like no one ever like
people i don't know people were a lot
more terrified of me just because i was
i always carried like heavy
anger maybe that's because my stepfather
though did you but did the way you dealt
with your trauma in uh at the home life
did it cross over into school like did
you bully or were you mean to any kids i
wasn't mean to anybody but i was just
always ready which is also at the same
time still kind of i don't think i know
a comic i don't think i know a really a
great comic
who isn't that have some trauma yeah i
just all this talk like but also at the
same time people think that that we're
just like that like people who think
we are depressed and i'm like i would
never get on stage if i was [ __ ]
depressed no that's the thing you know
what i mean like yeah yeah we came up
with trauma but like there's not a
darkness to chappelle no to me that's
true the people are there oh you gotta
be super dark and depressed it's like
yeah no there's comics that have that
sure but the majority of them don't hate
yeah i don't i don't yeah i agree with
you i mean dark is what is it what does
dark mean like i may have an imagination
for how bad it could get or yeah you
know versus how good it could be but
like families
like dark jokes no
there's that like you can tell some
comics are like really dark but they're
like a dark like you know like darkness
like a lot of musicians have it and not
even a lot there's a few the majority
don't well yeah it's like but majority
comics don't know but to me it's like i
already went through that [ __ ] so like
what do i have to be sad about now like
my life think about what we do for a
living
about this okay none of us are we're all
flawed but yeah i can genuinely say and
i think everybody hears the same way i
can genuinely say that i spend i've
spent the past 25 years of my life
trying to be funny what does that mean
i've tried i've been i spent my time
trying to make people laugh that's
literally what's at the forefront of my
brain and so are all my friends for the
most part i don't care whether it's a
good gig whether it's rogan or you or we
we may have our darkness or we may have
our but for the most part we spend our
time literally coming up with ways to
make people laugh and for the most part
that's what we do whether it's in
podcasting or stand up so if you're
going to hate on somebody there might be
other people that you want to target
that you want to put your hate on for
the most part right it doesn't make
sense but but the hate comes from a
jealousy stick
why should we even like try to even
understand it's like let that just be
what yeah yeah cause it's just it's jus
to me it just it's just gonna exist
regardless so it's like what of course
why should i let it like [ __ ] bother
me of course
i don't i don't pay attention to it but
yeah yeah but it's like i was thinking
about that as a group i'm proud of the
people that i know who are comics i'm
proud of my community i'm proud of like
what we do which is literally sit around
and try to be idiots
and use our trauma or our [ __ ] our
uh dysfunction
and we put it into something positive we
[ __ ] sit around and talk about it and
make people laugh and people go oh i'm
that way too or whatever so we almost
have like opposite situations like you
you went to a predominantly black school
it was like one of the and yours was
probably like uh well my second high
school uh well i went to like three
different high schools but yeah the
second high school like even when we
were in you didn't come with us that day
but even when we were in uh tacoma yeah
i think tacoma went down to the like bay
area and it was when i say white i'm
talking twilight white dude people were
clear and you know david's there and i
look at david like do you feel
uncomfortable like i feel like i'm
before you like i'm the close thing to
the [ __ ] minority that they have and
i'm yeah they're just being tan i stick
out yeah but do you feel weird he's like
no
yeah it's kind of hard to cause like i
mean even when i think because i've
always just felt like a kind of like an
outcast like with with any situation
like
you know just around like a bunch of
black people around a bunch of white
people i just you know like so it never
really like it was just like oh it's
kind of like natural it's just like
whatever like why should i feel
uncomfortable like i i know i don't fit
in you know i have like a lot of the
same interests as these people i think
that's kind of the breeding ground for
comedy because when you're a comic
you're on the outside looking in as a
kid i was always around i was never
around white people i was around people
who were arabic or i was around
pakistani or indian and then within that
when you go to an international school
every multinational company that was
there so from whether they're from korea
or china
they're all so they all go to school
there and they go to school i assume
like the parents make good money like if
they're traveling around like that sort
of like so they make i'm sure there's a
group like you guys who speak english
probably the parents aren't like
everybody's broke no no no they may but
what's interesting is that because
you're all uh living on compounds or the
company gives you a housing allowance
you're not the school itself is chaos
it's not like it's not it doesn't feel
wealth back then in the 70s it was all
bootlegged it was all they just would
put up uh they just put up some
structures and they'd bust in teachers
from the united states so it wasn't it
wasn't they like wasn't like great
sports facilities it was basically
[ __ ] chaos so in saudi arabia when i
was there the playground i promise you
was literally desert there was no it was
just you know i remember playing oh hot
you could it was 125 degrees you could
you could fry an egg on the face
no no so so that so much of that was and
everybody was in this strange position
so we would be you didn't know what they
were doing they might work for a certain
thing and they were making a way they
were making money but nobody was super
rich so when i went to greenwich
connecticut my dad comes back to new
york and he's and i'm in school i had to
go away to boarding school because the
schools don't go past eighth grade in
saudi arabia so now they're in saudi
arabia they do after eighth grade
uh they don't allow any foreigners
because they don't want drugs or delays
so i now i'm in eighth grade so i gotta
go i gotta go
interview
at these [ __ ] boarding schools in the
northeast i never lived in the states so
i'm it's just such a different place man
so i'm there i finally go to this
amazing school called northfield mount
hermon where 5 of the kids they were on
scholarship from all over the world so
it was this international crazy like
[ __ ] thing yeah yeah but what's
interesting is my dad he they get buy a
house in greenwich connecticut greenwich
connecticut is the whitest waspiest
place of all time with all the money
it's all the wall street money super bro
uh
have you i've been i've been
that's where it's it's the schools are
awful they're they're so good to schools
but if you don't have money or if you're
not in a click
back then
you're [ __ ] dead i didn't deal with
it
and entitled like that's remember this
is the 80s this was kind of a racist
time this was a time when when it was
you know the whole power structure was
was basically that see that's the beauty
of you like you you experienced like so
many different cultures look my friend
said to me one time my my buddy who was
who i went to boarding school with who
was black he goes he i remember he said
dude it's so funny because he he goes
you have nothing in common with these
people because i didn't grow up around
them yeah i didn't grow up around that
kind of white people i didn't make one
friend dude and granted that's so wild
yeah i couldn't make a [ __ ] friend
they were i remember that it was so
interesting they were all they they're
all super tall and super like waspy yeah
you're just not in it did you guys as
parents that would like talk to you all
about racism or anything like
so so my my they always tell a story
about how i didn't see color because i
grew up around so many different colors
so so my best friend in high school and
my roommate was black
and i was talking about him to my
parents i bring him home he happens to
be a black kid from north carolina
and
my father said i remember my father said
you never mentioned we had no idea we
just assumed he was a white kid
you never mentioned it it never even
dawned on you because yeah but again i
grew up where did i say that i grew up
in nothing but like i spent my time in
africa and in saudi arabia and around
all those people like racism's learned
though like that like yeah his best
friend strongly believes tiger's best
friend that josh kid his dad's black
jamaica well his mom's born and raised
in jamaica they grew up in england but
tiger he
i was also raised by my parents who are
not pr like who always
would never allow any help
my parents
my father and my mother i can honestly
say and my grandparents i i'm telling
you we're the least prejudiced people
i've ever known now my my grandparent my
my mom's side born raised in england old
school where it's just the way they were
they were raised you know especially
back then growing up in what the 40s
yeah where
they are not fans of black people yeah
they dropped the n word all the time and
i didn't understand it didn't make sense
yeah and my mom's like you can never use
those words she's like your grandma
that's that's her thing and that's the
way she was raised but you were not and
it was always like so like such a
powerful word
now remember when the kkk was [ __ ]
booming and aurora started to get really
like um
like urban the kkk went door to door
given pamphlets to join the kkk and we
got one and i came home from school i
walked home from in fourth grade and i
opened the pamphlet and it was a cake he
came in like the night like yeah it was
gone i couldn't sleep at night i started
crying and my dad kept having to come in
in the room he's like why are you crying
i was like i saw that that that kkk
thing my dad's like listen dude because
i wouldn't stop crying i'm so scared i
was like don't come to the house my
dad's like
they're not gonna do anything to you
because you're white yeah he's like quit
crying wow and i was like what think
about being black i i saw jesus
door-to-door
that's funny i saw a rock i was so
scared yeah i saw real racism it's like
a hood and then he was like joined well
yeah i look scary yeah i saw i saw
genuine racism when so one of the things
about saudi arabia is you make friends
with all the kids and a lot of those
kids are military kids yeah and a lot of
those kids are from the south and back
in the 70s
back in the 70s if you were like a
southern white guy
the n word i never heard it really when
i was in saudi arabia now when i went to
visit them in states like maryland
or other states in the south
i can remember so well and in florida i
went to visit my friends grandparents we
we went there for spring break
and they were telling n-word jokes and
they were using the word all the time
and i remember because i grew up
that was a bad word man you would never
use that word in my [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
and i also thought that was a thing of
the past that's how naive i was because
again i grew up with how i grew up so i
remember hearing that [ __ ] and i was i
called my mother and i was like these
people are using these people are
prejudiced there i thought this was i
thought that you know what i thought
when you watch old westerns and the
black guy is you know treated that way
that's what i thought i was like there
this is like the old west i remember
thinking it's like you just thought old
men i didn't [ __ ] know i couldn't
fight it was the only time i remember
being my feelings got hurt yeah the guy
said his my great the grandfather of my
friend said there were always black
people in the water and he said look at
all of them in the bla in the water over
there you wonder why the water doesn't
turn black
and i and i and i said wow i remember i
was a kid i was [ __ ] 17 i remember
getting so angry yeah i said i said
they're exactly like everybody else and
he goes you think so he was an italian
guy you think so that's all i heard it's
tough back then right because they were
like obviously
that was only
85 1985 before a lot of people were born
so i did
that was 85 when that happened a racist
place
you know my dad loves you because my
dad's best friend even to this day it's
his best friend his name is claude who's
a black and they tell weed together
he's like you're like me because he's
like my best friend was a black guy
named claude he's like he looked a lot
like chappelle but taller
so when he met chappelle he did like
this weird like black handshake and i
was so embarrassed oh it was so funny
i was like what's up baby he pulled me
in i was like oh but i was like what's
up baby all right drive turkey i'm like
dad i can't stand him feels racist
he's he's just trying to connect that's
all even when he saw this
is like like i think his
his dad's white and his dad's white yeah
when he saw him in the green room in
denver he's like what's up baby what's
your favorite hot sauce i was like
yeah yeah
he's like you beating them chilling you
like them chillings i was like dad why
are you can you leave the green room
please you're trying to come back
like please don't do this my dad my dad
at 81 does not give a [ __ ] he had blood
in his urine and they were like checking
them for [ __ ] all kinds of stuff
he's got kidney stones because the dude
doesn't drink water he could give him
like
you got to start drinking water those
are going to hurt coming out bro he's
got like shards of glass in his platter
meanwhile like like at toast at dinner
all these people around and hey guys no
blood in my urine anymore hey
everybody's looking around like all
right bro i got my haircut yesterday
from this new guy
i don't know what drug he was on meth
all the adderall in the world i just sat
down and it was i didn't get a single
word out and he it all started like this
he goes you in the crypto man i go
what he goes you in the crypto man i go
now i know i know about it but it says
you have in my investments and other
things like real estate and start legos
man i thought they were doing the
conversation bro i got an hour in my ear
about crypto and the store like you it
was the most insane
character i've ever encountered in my
life i i got done i call my gargoyle i'm
exhausted she's like this and he goes
you know i think about crypto man and i
didn't know man i you know i live with
my parents so the thing is
my parents man you know i'm trying to
get them invested in doing that yeah i
think it'd be good for you he's like
because you know i got a 0.02 and it's
the ts crypto thing so i get a 0.02 and
i think it's seven dollars now so you
know i made 100 million dollars so the
100 million dollars i'll translate that
and the thing i go yeah and you're cool
like the security your money is oh man
he starts laughing and he goes
security he was thinking about this man
thinking about this because think about
if i have an uh transaction with
somebody in china it goes like that so
your chance of visiting this is the kind
of energy the dogs bark dude
[Applause]
non-stop an hour straight an hour
straight of that and i get daniel well
uh good luck with your your crypto man
and he was hey he was uh do you think
rogan be in this crypto business because
what i could do is i could call him and
i go well no let me give you his name
let me give you his number
the answer is yes
rogan
i don't know hey man you gotta be a
picture my uncle man he's in the crypto
too we're gonna picture my legs
i'm exhausted right now i i was like i
had a neighbor she was this woman just
she was just
whatever happened to her i don't know
she'd get a check and unemployment check
and she would this is in venice and she
would use all of it to just do all the
cocaine that it was a friday she would
get it on friday or something and she
would just do and i knew friday was when
to avoid her eyes would be looking 10
different directions i'm walking my dog
i had a rescue dog he was a bad little
[ __ ] but you got to be respectful to a
rescue dog because they've been
traumatized a little dog cuter [ __ ]
cuter [ __ ] um uh and
she comes up to me and she's
like that and you can see and my dog
just goes dogs
the dog goes
and the dog's trying to get away yeah
and she's trying to get at it and so she
kind of and i'm distracted as usual i
got my [ __ ] and she goes i love you i
can see my dog backed up to the wall he
can't get away and she goes i love you
and i'm like
she got her face and he just goes
right on the [ __ ] nose and then she
without missing a beat but she's like oh
you baby baby i go you got to stop shame
taser dude who bit her so hard and i
thought i was done i thought i ended up
having to he tried to do that to a kid i
had to give him away
but long story short she never did
anything she just [ __ ] walked around
with a little child
because a celebrity who got bit by a dog
remember that on a talk show i remember
we brought up that girl one time from
nine news
they're like this is a little pimple oh
yeah yeah yeah like like don't put your
face on the top of your lip up don't put
your face to a dog's face that's a
challenge you don't know the big
challenge
[ __ ] that you mean the the the dragon
thingy
the what dragon yeah what the it just
showed up i don't like komodo dragon
you're talking about that one or she's
bit by komodo dragon i don't know i'd
like sharon stone's husband
oh boy
no wait i thought those komodo dragons
are like this
i don't like seeing dogs bite somebody's
face no it's tough
because they can do some crazy damage
and then that i fee that uh barbara goes
yeah i go you gotta i'm just trying to
change the [ __ ] topic of crypto i was
exhausted uh hey you got a girl man and
he goes yeah i had a girl man we
actually just broke up man you know the
thing is i broke up with her she she got
with this bill in her man and uh that
was her husband and she got a divorce
man but the thing is you know she uh you
know he he's still around her it's her
fiance man and then and then she she's
an assistant billionaire but she got a
big ass man once when she was assistant
billion i was like i'm out i was like oh
god damn god dude wow you go through so
many barbers it's not a badass
not a bad character you're doing there
it's nuts
that's why i was like that's me i've
never encountered anybody like this in
my life that's why i was like you go
ahead and talk about me on the podcast
man i know you make fun of me i'm like
just shut up
and i'm going to i beg you and now you
are i went from that to that [ __ ]
weird chuck e cheese steak restaurant i
got home and i was just i was like i
just gotta sit in silence what's always
awkward is like you never like you
didn't reply to anything but he just
wants to [ __ ] go oh and then he and
then he's like yeah man you know the
thing is because uh the thing about who
controls the world and this isn't on
some comp conspiracy [ __ ] man he said
who controls the world i'm like i know
where he's going i'm like banks
he's like see you you're a genius dog
he goes there's genius in all of us
there's genius and you can you can't do
what you do if you weren't a genius like
okay i appreciate it but i'm not genius
you know you are though everybody has
genus in him you just gotta find him
like all right dude and then he's like
yeah like who controls the world banks
banks control the world so when you
think about it man it's like when we
when when we ended slavery in 1772 when
we got our independence like he's like
and lincoln did that like
you're thinking
i went are you thinking of july 4th
independence day goes he stops use
yeah
yeah you're right and i go and that
lincoln didn't do that studios
so anyways so when you think about elon
musk think about it he's in with the
banks so when with deutsche coin when he
shits on deutsche coin it drops he's
doing on purpose man because the banks
i'm like oh my god dude oh my god dude i
see it all the time like you gave a [ __ ]
at all
i hate those people that don't i'm not
exaggerating dude i didn't get a single
word and then i was like trying to text
you guys or my girl just so it shut up
and see you guys on my phone he goes
i'll wait i'll wait you texting i'll
wait i'll wait oh and then i'd finish my
text like how's the haircut
oh right he gives a good fate yeah
you know i just hate people that don't
understand i can't go i can't i can't go
back it was man next one on me man nice
one on the house i'm like that's
tempting to sit through this again
i can't
that kind of stuff like people that just
don't understand [ __ ]
dealing as a comic when you deal with
you but you can't go anything that thing
is like
why wouldn't you leave i'm like he's cut
my [ __ ] hair yeah i have to sit down
for an hour and take this ear beating so
i get my [ __ ] haircut it's the only
time you see he doesn't do that weed is
not an annoying like wheat will calm you
down
yeah yeah we chill yeah yeah dude it
hasn't been cocaine admiral math
adderall coke
um those are not good drugs man you know
so so so when we ended slavery when we
got our independence week right
1772 man and when lincoln gives our
independence from uh
from uh no not the chinese uh i went
from the british goes yeah see you a
genius man so the thing is i'm like no i
went to fifth
that in the grade
grade yeah i my friend used to date that
he'd find the dumbest the dumbest girl
okay the prettiest and thomas i can't do
it who didn't know
they didn't know things like uh
they just didn't know basic education
when what fourth of july
meant at all and i'm not kidding and
it'd be so and my friend would be so
[ __ ] embarrassed
because he some guys come from
conservative families so they want to
marry uh their mother but they can't get
it up so they have to get so they like a
chew toy they like an absolute
professional like a real and and they
this girl would come to dinner and we'd
all be hanging around and she'd just
have the biggest fakest hits that would
just be popping out my friend
my friend would go but
he was so embarrassed he go oh he didn't
tell me all these oh i got this
button
yeah
i mean yeah
i tell my girl that all the time like
when we go these parent teachers think
i'm like well put your tits to it
but you get to put those big titties
away what are you doing should we just
wearing a shirt i'm a girl's classic you
know she's super excited and she can't
help but i'm like yeah you gotta she's
your body's
well i'd be like i'd see her and she's
very classy like the one thing the first
thing i said about her yeah the first
thing i said when you met her and and my
ex said it she he goes watch watch this
girl watch how she looks at the children
watch how she connects to children
because she's very classy she's like
italian mexican and she just knows that
and she's always dressed actually really
well but her body
is simply ridiculous it's like a
bodybuilder you ever see a bodybuilder
who's who's
wears a suit but they you're just like
your body is you could just i would say
joe i'd be like joe
honestly this is ridiculous like you're
you can't walk around like that but and
if guys look at her you know it's like
you bought a ferrari of course people
gonna start your [ __ ] ferrari but
then we were in the mall the other day
with the kids and this girl is like
barely wearing anything and has the
biggest blowout ass and she's like oh
you're just gonna [ __ ] stare at it
like
what i go who's not yeah it's like a
lamborghini pulled up i gotta see what
the [ __ ] going on right i go every but
i want joe everybody's looking like like
that's we you have it's like a car
accident right she noticed it i'm i'm
like i mean so you're just going to
stare i'm like no but it's the
equivalent of of just releasing
50 bunnies 50 baby bunnies onto a floor
yeah you're gonna just keep being like
nope here we go like whoa oh look at all
the bunnies like those are giraffes what
the [ __ ] do you want me to do it'd be
like releasing a bag of cobras and
they're hissing and you're like no way
dude not today
like i have i'm like you know every but
the entire mall's looking i'm gonna look
at that like her it's like it's i'm
trying to say is it real is it
the same thing with this girl walk by
she had
she had a impossibly tight shirt she
went to the children's store the baby
gap and bought a baby gap t-shirt and
then had to cut it like this and then
she had the biggest hits with pierce
nipples and just
i mean it was it was just shotgun
titties right and i was like what the
[ __ ] are we doing gotta look
now my girlfriend really i'm like well
yeah yeah i mean of course
it's literally like a [ __ ]
lamborghini pulled up you guys
did you guys ever do the sneak look
sometimes oh i'll oh if it's a dime
piece i'll go like this now
and then then she'll keep and i'll go
hold on is hold on but is the restaurant
back there
she's like we've been there a hundred
[ __ ] times like no but i were they
doing
were they doing construct i'll go were
they doing construction
she's like what the [ __ ] all i can do is
just see the girl oh
you're a [ __ ] i'm like what no i'm
trying like the target move over
and then i'll just keep is it over there
you're all taking your head off
scratching your head
and then like my son's like dad it's
over here i'm like nine shut the [ __ ] up
uh
vegas and then i'll then when she's out
of my saddle yo you're right you're
right it's over here i'm sorry i got i
get really confused you know what i you
know what it's that it's at the
i'm thinking of the growth yeah that's
what i'm thinking sometimes we're at the
mall and with i'm thinking of the growth
sometimes you have to my girl goes
there's like a [ __ ] target at the
grove
holy [ __ ] you're right all right let's
go
you're right my brain be [ __ ] up
sometimes yeah
i'm off today i'm off today that's rare
that i did that in vegas the whole i
literally was like i think it's back we
should probably and i would turn all the
way around but it has to but it has to
be like a
bombshell for me to pull that there are
bombshells the problem is especially at
the mall the problem is there there are
bombshells where you will take the heat
because you got to take it in oh it
seems like hey every time you stare at
that bombshell i'm going to stab you
with a shank like [ __ ] do it [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah god i gotta
i have my i just have skulls
because a lot of times you're you're
like looking for a flaw because a lot of
times you're like there's no way she's
that perfect yeah
well
okay actually she is i'm telling you do
that with your girl just make something
just [ __ ]
like it's [ __ ] home depot
you're in a mall that makes sense is
there a [ __ ] depot over there
she's like that what i needed a tool i'm
like [ __ ]
can i get a ladder damn
i did this the other day i was looking
and my girl goes really and i go i'm
looking at the guy yeah
no you do muscular the guy is
which usually is true by the way that is
very true that is you see yeah that's a
fair thing and then if you catch me
again i don't go ugh you believe that
yeah trash where's that she's trash
oh my god why is she wearing i'll be
like have a little respect am i right i
mean she's she's oh she's just gonna
have her ass in those jeans like what
are you doing yeah i'm like my
girlfriend
nasty i'm like i'll tell you what man i
wouldn't have it if i'm her dad
i mean she's a tent
[ __ ] disgusting you ask me i'm like
i'm not even into that can you you some
guys like that yeah like that big ass
because some guys
lip liner and long nails and all that
jewelry and my girl like you find that
attracting like no you like you think
she works out i don't know it's probably
fake if you my girl's like she probably
had a lot of work done like disgusting
[ __ ]
like i went straight this is all in
agreement
i'll tell you that right now
i mean spy hasn't even read a book yeah
you just try to all you do is break them
down i'm like i bet she's dumb as [ __ ]
don't dove double i think i was [ __ ]
dumb dud would be so honest about that
dove david i would be like i like a girl
in a fiero
with the the [ __ ] dice is hanging
from the [ __ ] he goes if i see that
that hits on if i see that she's got a
cheap shoe i want cheap shoes and a
cheap handbag and i want chip nails that
heats me the [ __ ] up oh good i like a
girl who has to stay in a motel and i
was like or or like you go these parent
things you know because you're tiger
have some friends and their moms are
just [ __ ] tense and joanna
you're awfully friendly with [ __ ]
daniel's mom like
i mean tiger's friends with her freaking
son what do you want to do yes she has
giant titties we all know this can we
all accept this giant
and they're out yeah what do you want me
to do
she brought them out right we're just
talking i'm talking to her about her kid
yeah that's why she's married to a super
rich athlete etc yes so yeah yeah that's
that's uh that's the same thing whenever
we have a birthday party at the house
and some of those moms are just you're
just like oh okay
all right yeah and somehow over level
five myself staring and then now we're
in a conversation
and you know people are they're all
shaking their head and then you change
the subject
i gotta go over here because frankly
you're
way too hot to be talking about i can't
wait
yeah that's fun
well then then divorce happens and then
people are
single and the whole thing's a mess
all right what do you got
what's up kids a lot of y'all going bald
out there a lot of you using losing your
hair you don't know what to do two out
of three bros will experience some form
of hair loss by the time they're 35 it's
not good
thanks
thank you thanks
thank you to my friends at keeps the
keeps offers a simple stress free way to
keep your hair man low cost treatments
are just ten dollars per month it keeps
offers generic versions discrete little
package proven results we got you
covered keeps has more than five star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key keep what you have man
because once it's gone you're just gonna
have to wear toupee treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
right now if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
fighter that's k-e-e-p-s dot com fighter
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps.com fighter to get
your first month free keeps.com fighter
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter
i used to feel drained after riding my
bike for a few hours or when i was
working out especially after deadlifts
but not anymore
not anymore thanks to true nigerian true
nigerian fuels the body's energy engines
maintain cellular metabolism even
supports heart health i have more energy
right now with 11 published human
clinical studies backed by nobel prize
winners true nigerian is a supplement
that is clinically proven to boost nad
levels all right we got required we got
you uh covered man cellar energy and
repair thanks to true nigerian since
taking true nitrogen it helps your
muscles recover after your workout or
after your bike ride what you're trying
to do it helps you have more zest a
little pep in your step and right now
new customers can save 10 percent off
your first purchase by going to
truenigen.com fighter use code fighter
that's trueniogen.com fighter
t-r-u-n-i-a-g-e-n
dot com slash fighter code fighter to
save temps off your first purchase these
statements have not been evaluated by
the food and drug administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat or cure or prevent any disease
truenigeon.com fighter code fighter
what's up tinkies this thursday friday
saturday economy store la jolla we
coming that's this week all shows are
damn near sold out we might add a show
late thursday but right now a few
tickets left thursday friday saturday in
la jolla california right outside san
diego my favorite club the comedy store
but this podcast is brought to you by on
it.com on it.com fighter temps off the
entire god damn site what do you need
alpha brain krill oil protein powders we
got keto stuff your boy's keto right now
i'm lightheaded because i don't have any
carbs so i apologize if i mess up on any
of this whatever you need though on it
got you covered you might be thick but
be healthy thick man be a sexy thick
thick with three c's on it.com fighter
10 off we got battle ropes we got coffee
we got steel club maces quad maces we
got on-demand streaming fitness home
fitness programs anything you need to
get your fat ass in shape on it gotcha
covered all right on it.com fighter temp
set off
i'm not saying i'm just saying in
general
that's a lot my buddy was a lot my buddy
it's hard to walk the line yeah but some
father my buddy's f he's he's like dude
best thing about having kids and divorce
is picking your kids up at school and
the other moms that are divorced
i don't
they're thirsty man oh yeah they come
ready like huh they're picking the kids
all dressed up they got the [ __ ]
mm-hmm you know they got to watch out
for them wearing a mean coat for the
kids yeah it's a play date i had this
just
gargoyle of a mom probably 300 pounds oh
boy we're getting ice cream tiger goes
oh his name's travis he's like travis
what's up he's like can travis come over
and play i'm like what can travis come
over and play i'm like uh we'll freak
out buddy mom's like yeah i'll take him
i'll take your number i'm like you
no no no
yeah i'll take your number and we'll
come over saturday i'm like no you can't
though i'm like a big dude with a gut i
know right oh it was chris farley
with tits yeah i'll take your number
we'll come over like how many beers do
they have yeah and i can i give her my
number she have taco meat and her beers
yes
you know i don't want to be rude like
you're my number how saturday works for
you i'm like it's just not i went we're
swamp saturday we'll figure it out
target's like i want to stay on my
tracks camera i want because mom's being
fat that's what you get you can't come
over the house because i don't want that
warlock in my house how about that tiger
you're faster if you want if you want
dad to be real with you you're instilled
i want to talk to that warlock for an
hour while you guys play basketball
he's just saying warlock so
yeah do you mind if he comes over hey
what's your number dude it was so
intense
dad i understand why he can't play
because his mom's super ugly that's why
and i don't want to talk she'll stab you
up
she's all right brother i'll see you
later
took a [ __ ] sorry
is there a [ __ ] around yeah you got a
bathroom in this place i ate all the
clams gonna destroy that thing
i'm telling you man i was like oh you're
not you can't close that's like my
friend i just we knew this girl and she
said that she goes
she's i want you to set me up with your
friends
30 minutes later i gotta take a [ __ ]
like you won't believe me oh the bunny
goes i wonder why you can't find this
boyfriend my name is regina i wonder why
you can't find a boyfriend regina
disgusting dude
all right what do you got
so [ __ ] was regina cute i know
you know why not it all depends
depending on what's not enough guys will
put up yeah exactly i just remember she
went like this i never forgot she went
i'm gonna take her [ __ ] like you won't
believe me oh no she was curing her
teeth and i was
she wasn't all right it's just when you
see that it's hard to deal
you know i don't know too many girls
just
blow up bathrooms do you girl blow up
your bathroom too no but sometimes i
can't even fart sometimes she probably
she has to right like sometimes when she
goes to bathroom she says get away stay
in the living room and then she does she
don't think that damn she won't let me
know this i mean it's a natural thing
for humans i know but you know the
show's like very exciting
we've been together what eight years
i've never heard her fart
ever have you ever never on accident i
guess wrestling with a tiger like movies
like did you get all that better and ice
cream no i go goddamn tiger and he's
like that wasn't me like this sure did
sound like it buddy
it is a weird thing huh it's just
awkward it's awkward i let it rip oh you
do yeah i can't live straight i can't
live
without being able to just let her know
my house is clean like like a 1950s
house dude we keep it tight yeah your
house is super you keep it tight [ __ ]
tight yeah yeah what about you chappelle
what are you far in front of your girl
now i don't know did your girl be in
front of you hell no it's just that all
and also i just i just hate that [ __ ]
it's like why do you need to you
couldn't go in another room or something
oh i'll do the silencer though i'll grab
our big pillows and like my girl's like
wait still not telling me i don't know
my [ __ ] tailbone hurts because it's
silent it's like a silencer you fart in
the pillow and it just silences them
yeah oh but then that thing is a bomb
and you can sew it across it's not like
foods you can't eat i can't i can't
touch broccoli
broccoli or beans
beans don't bother me broccoli bro
bombs over baghdad
brussels sprouts yup brussels sprouts
asparagus broccoli and and garlic
actually for me garlic white like garlic
makes daddy fart huh oh dude or or beans
it's a disaster just [ __ ] sound
disaster oh my stepmom has to since i've
known she's taking bino because like
dairy or beans i guess she'll just fart
yeah me and my brother were talking
about because we were going walking to
the car the car show on sunday i ripped
a big ass fart and tigers laughing and
jay's like do you remember dad farting
like hard i'm like yeah cause we my dad
take us on walks every night like we'd
walk miles every single night oh we
should stay in shape every night we'd
walk miles and miles miles at night like
eight o'clock at night that's how we'd
end our night with our dad and as soon
as we get out there he just ripped the
biggest farts remember was like you
remember how annoyed we were and my dad
would always go better out here than
there am i right and we're like
you said that last night though dude you
know
did you write any new material or are
you just going to use that every single
night we just take you for long walks oh
miles we'd walk a mile is that right
wow every night just walk in the
neighborhood every night every night
that's pretty nice that's cool that's
actually pretty cool we had no choice
but i get your shoes on and we just
walked that out we'd be gone for i don't
know i love a good walk in the
neighborhood oh i love it yeah
especially at night it's nice i do
that's having my son it has great
workouts every single night
what do you got jim
okay wait real quick i remember you be
farting in front of girls you look like
a farter you do look like a farter you
look like you don't give a [ __ ]
christian you you look like the first
date farter no you look like a farter no
i get embarrassed i can't
like if someone if i'm taking like a
mean [ __ ] in the bathroom and like with
where there's a lot of gas if someone
comes into there i can't like i have to
hold it because i'm embarrassed let me
do let me give you a little tip if you
do gotta drop a hot [ __ ] and there's a
party what do you if there's hopefully
there's a candle in there and there's
matches blow the matches out because the
smoke will mask any it overpowers the
matches are better than like the handle
you should just or you light the candle
and let it burn for a second then blow
the candle out and smoke well it will
get rid of anything dude i was that's a
problem
i've done two tv shows one was mad tv
and the other was a another show i did
you're doing more than two tv no i'm
saying where the guys there there was
one guy on each cast
who i remember i never forgot this i
didn't know anybody was just like i
they'd known each other for a week and i
was the new guy on mad tv and one of the
actors just we're all on a roll
on a staircase on renmar just standing
out we're all sitting on the staircase
like in a clump and he just goes
he goes
ah [ __ ]
oh i hate that [ __ ]
i was like and the girl's like you're
disgusting he's like that was a good one
that was a good one i was like this guy
does not give a [ __ ] then but also you
know in fifth grade then we're doing
death valley and we have to all crowd we
all have to run and the scene is you run
from the you run from the [ __ ] uh
zombie and then we had to cut around the
corner and wait until he said cut so
everybody's waiting
we're on a comp and you just hear my boy
go
on purpose
we all [ __ ]
like my dad ripped farts but
we were born like like even now when my
jay was out here he gets out here
tomorrow too you might see him i hope so
but he gets out tomorrow but even jay
like
we you know we worked out then we got
coffee and we i we're driving he's all
quiet i see him sweating what's wrong
with you guys
where do you uh like where do you go
after this i'm like well we'll go to the
studio like is there um is there a
bathroom at the new studio i'm like oh
you got a [ __ ]
he's like i don't understand dude you
you haven't been in the bathroom all
morning so you're just gonna like drive
around do all your stuff like i'll
figure it out man he's like
it's like a clean bathroom where we're
going like holy [ __ ] you gotta drop a
[ __ ] damn and he's all embarrassed he's
like nah just you know just is there a
key he's like
and he was how far is the studio i can
tell he has to show you it's like 10
minutes away dude he goes maybe we
should stop at home for you know jay's
like maybe we should stop at home first
we should stop at home first that means
that means one thousand percent stop at
home i'm gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] porsche
i went nah you'll be all right let's get
to the studio are you are you a right in
the morning
take a dumb guy yeah i am
i uh up every single morning 5 30 to 6
if i'm lucky like 6 10 usually 5 45 5 30
when tyler wakes up and i make my coffee
and i drink my coffee and then
the horns go
we don't stay in hotels yeah i'm saying
if you're on vacation oh my uh
that's a good point
oh i'll run the shower i create all the
steam so it's like a hot [ __ ] steam and
then uh
then hopefully with all the soap and
shampoo it that that will kind
i'll play music
i'll play music i'll mask everything wow
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] oh i'm like the
nightstalker i mean it's your wife
yeah but we keep it sexy though man
she's so
wait so
did you guys ever date someone my my
longest term girlfriend before this one
she would want me to far we had this
thing where i talk where we were in bed
and she's like can you fart in front of
me i'm far in front of you because she
wanted to be like closer like a bond
it was like a bond thing with with
farting she felt like we would be closer
if we could fight
the bond and so i'll eat some broccoli
and then i ruin your [ __ ] all right
but we both did it you know it was weird
you both did it we both like now she
went back i went prayer and it was weird
no absolutely not but there was like a
bond thing you gotta you know broke up
right after that not right after girls i
don't get it i don't get it right
yeah so she had a flat ass so it sounded
like you're ripping [ __ ] she had a
booty she had a booty
yeah yeah she had a booty oh she had a
booty yeah oh yeah what kind of asian
was she then vietnamese most of my
girlfriends were videos
okay yeah but don't do that no that was
yeah but it was like
booties
nowadays i think a lot of them have
surgery too yeah that surgery is popping
these things what's popping
it's also the most dangerous surgery you
know that i didn't know that yeah ass
surgery is by far the most dangerous you
can get right the one with the implants
are with fat both the one with fats even
more dangerous interesting
okay so man this is interesting
yeah i remember that the iconic remember
this
i thought this i did this current event
for you i thought this kid was kurt
cobain's kid no all right yeah he has a
daughter oh yeah i don't know yeah no
no that was just the baby they used for
the
so the headline is man photographed as
baby on never mind cover sues nirvana
alleging child porno well he's trying to
suit what he's doing now yeah now scroll
down he just wants to make sure he's
suing like a bunch of the members even a
previous member that replaced dave grohl
as a drummer oh the the members i'm
sorry that they've grown
well when you see the guy like
chad channing wasn't on this album what
is it exactly that's why it's weird
that's why it's weird spencer eldon the
man who's unusual baby portrait was used
for the most recognized album covers of
all time nirvana's nevermind filed a
lawsuit tuesday legend of the new image
constituted child porno what the album
cover depicts eldon underwater and
swimming pool yeah we know what the [ __ ]
it is has driven by that statement on
the capitalism he's just looking for
money
what happens is when you file a suit the
the they see that so so the press sees
it they get up they get a notification
so anytime you file a suit with the
county registrar's office whatever the
[ __ ] it is uh all the press gets it so
they'll they'll so they go oh look and
now what happens is either the their
lawyers say you can fight this if you
want it's not going to go anywhere
it's going to cost you money it's going
to cost some more money hundreds of
thousands yeah at least if this [ __ ]
[ __ ] dum-dum wants it
and what he's looking for is for them to
just make it go away because they don't
know how to yeah because you in in the
lawyer
he's looking for for nirvana to just
anytime you see like someone suing
another person yeah the person with the
most money is going to win every single
yeah you can if you have enough money
you can drag you can ride it out yeah
it's going to cost like let's say not
i'm saying like if so let's say i have
10 million dollars you have a million
and you're suing me
i'm like you're giving me to go maybe
one round of this i'll go 10. that's the
problem that's the [ __ ] and i'm going to
win
you want to you only have you only have
the gas tank for one round i have ten
rounds and lawsuits are so expensive
like you you're asking for a hundred
thousand from each of the defendants
yeah and there's a bunch of defendants
so you'll never get that there's a bunch
of defenders yeah but the hundred fifty
thousand is a key thing right it's not
like it's a crazy amount yeah
when you see him you're like this makes
total sense and he also posed for
pictures as he was an adult like later
on in life post for the same picture
yeah it was like an anniversary
hey dude we could do something with this
they're not gonna get [ __ ] so someone
hyped them up it wasn't even a high
level it probably wasn't even his
thought until someone probably of course
lawyers are incredible yeah and then i
guess
it shows the lawyer representing
representatives yeah but he looks like
the guy who would write a hate comment
on reddit
it was considered they were saying
consider child pornography because it
was a baby chasing
money like a the monetary thing is what
made it challenging but
non-sexualized nude photos of them
infants are generally not considered
porno under the law so there's nothing
sexual about this do you think he'll get
any money like if you sense that you
don't think dude nirvana first of all
the the lawyer who represents nirvana's
can be a monster he's going to eat this
guy alive and his shitload yeah he's
going to tell me like that the big time
moore's not taking this case off spencer
because they know that it's just a loss
there's no way to win lawyers want money
yeah yeah
let's see
that's him right there
you see he would do he wouldn't even
even has never mind tattooed on his
chest yeah that's a lost man
yeah i mean let's start this
without anything and he redid the
multiple times like a ton of times like
that's not going to cut it like
obviously you played ball
yeah we did so we made money off it or
at least profiteered in some way over it
possible
let's [ __ ] with that notice how much
even has kirk cobain here go the one
where he has the beanie on
and that'd be a loser ladies and
gentlemen
it's just a way to make money it is i
mean it's a i'm sure there's a bunch of
lawyers in his year like get a job
crouch you can make money so but but
okay but if a lawyer
you said a lawyer wouldn't really take
this kind of case then then why why
would a lawyer be i mean some lawyers
would well definitely like blow like
low-level lawyers you're gonna try and
take this on because they think there's
something there
but they're they're just trying to take
money from him you mess with nirvana you
messed with the big dogs yeah the
lawyers get a percentage
whatever you want from the case and he
wants 150 from every person
you know how powerful that guy is
you don't want to [ __ ] with those guys
because you know what they do because
then when you do that they go well let's
look into this guy and then you're going
to dig up all your dirt ever yep and go
you sure you want to do this because we
found out you did you know the sexual
assault kit or whatever yeah when you
were 17. you want to come out with this
yeah i think he's like yeah i'm good
true yep
this is true oh all right they're a
little vape pen meatball no i'm just
like a little stuffed you don't have a
vape no no i mean what what i was hoping
you did dude
i smoking on the road dude you got to
get a vape response
what do you say are you coming to us
you're going to come to san diego yeah
yes sir you are yeah
you're bringing that that that spliff
i will oh my god chappelle and mark
smoked the spliff you know split his
marijuana and tobacco together
chappelle smoked it i've never seen him
so [ __ ] high in my life pull up a
picture of me i was like talking he's
laughing his ass i'm like well this
isn't that funny
you thought i was kevin hart the story
the highest i ever got was when i kind
of had you being awesome
oh yeah i remember that because that was
a blunt
i was tore up yeah yeah zoom in on
chappelle's eyes oh my god dude you look
i was gonna say a lot of weeds
do i smoke a lot of weed uh no that's
cultural it's very like i get both of
them
i didn't realize your eyes are there i
ran into brenda's meet and greet i was
just like i didn't know where i was yeah
yeah do you know i do the meet greetings
stumbles but he's like
i was like chappelle what is going on
with you dude whoa he's just laughing
and i look at mark he's like
yeah
mark kept going there's a place of ocean
i was like you two are so highly i need
you to exit
were you okay though were you paranoid
or was it fine oh my paranoid i was fine
he didn't know there there was uh
marijuana in that thing let me say a
picture with you and tj that's cool
look at that man
go to the one with jason how tall is tj
i know i was just gonna think i'm saying
the same thing short are you sure don't
fight him hey i will not go to the uh
one of the his first bit the top left
with the crew
loving the crew look at jay's kool-aid
smile i know he has them the happiest
person on the planet and our biggest
eyes too like always wide open someone
said it looks uh on mark because mark
posted it said someone said uh
jay looks like the molly just kicked in
he does
he looks bigger too like buffer yeah
jay's big yeah jake jacked
all right what do you got all right this
one is pretty crazy this is in belgium
this [ __ ] is crazy yeah this woman
believes she's having an affair with
this chimpanzee has she ever hooked up
with him no because it's through the
glass oh yeah so she's she's loved this
she says that she loves the champ
chimpanzee the chimpanzee loves her and
he really does oh she's crazy
yeah because he's you know i guess with
in the chimpanzee i guess groups if one
kind of bonds with a human more they
kind of get kicked out of the group so
what's happening with this one
for messing with this [ __ ] so she's not
allowed to go to the zoo anymore and
she's really heartbroken and now she's
driving yeah
she
yeah wow
do you know how batshit crazy you have
to be that you connected with the
chimney there you go for four years over
four years i think i bet you it does
though i bet you it sees her and i bet
you doesn't i bet that trip does that to
every human no no no particularly
no so this chimpanzee came from a home
too before but then it got crazy so
that's why they went to the zoo you know
like crazy what do you mean dangerous
yeah dangerous yeah this jim trying to
[ __ ]
that one [ __ ] that had he was like
feeding the chips that's such a horrible
story the
[ __ ] wine
and he had a robot
and then he went you know what dude i
don't like your friend i'm gonna rip her
face off yeah you haven't seen her and
her fingers bring it up chin and she's
such a horrible surgery and the doctor
was like we did our best they get he
gave the xanax wine
they [ __ ] and
oh yeah the face is so horrible though i
can't no
clicking on that this one this so when
she got a surgery the doctor we tried
her best though you know she she gave it
wine and [ __ ] no this is her friend she
got a face transplant you got jealous
for some reason it was upset about her
she's gotten she's at it better she
looks identical to the guy of hannibal
there you go um i mean that that's
that'll just make your whole life took
her eyes out everything yeah
your friends [ __ ] the chimp that's
you know that's so awful where's her
friend but no that's a chimp doing chimp
[ __ ] what do you mean he's awful that's
it
oh that's that's what they do
this poor lady look ripped our hands and
face off
this is why you shouldn't suck chimps
off
it's so terrible the strength of a
[ __ ] chimp i know and she calls the
cops or i think the friend doesn't they
have the 911 call and she's like get
here now he's ripping her hands off
because jim's going for her face and
your hands then you're dead genitals
yeah
bitter it's so sad she's like you didn't
rip your tits off chimps are [ __ ]
savage she did everything to her that
was her before i guess then she got an
oprah that poor poor woman she did yeah
it's horrible it's so horrific oh okay
this was oh yeah okay i remember this
only because i used to watch it but this
way you don't make friends with chips
that's why i don't [ __ ] you yeah dude
yeah well yeah it's jim's doing chicken
was [ __ ] this no her friend
the owner was hooking up with the champ
brought the and then the lady was like
oh i want to see the champ she's like
yeah come over and he was trying to
enjoy his glass of wine he's in a robe
and you know she had changed her hair
she got her hair done and the chimp
decided i don't like that hair
and something and then she stabbed the
chimp the the owner stabbed the chimp
and the chimp just looked at her
like that and then the cops came shot
that chimp like five times
chimp got shot with a nine millimeter i
think with those like hollow point and
the chimp still climbed up on the
[ __ ] roof
i was like oh cool
and then was just so and then came back
down and i think ultimately died after
got shot some more
that's how [ __ ] hard horrific story
and this is why people shouldn't have
know
200 pounds why do you want to [ __ ]
chill why are you putting the chimp in a
robe and have them sleep in your bed and
sucking them off well that trend that
chimp had already bitten somebody before
that and then that woman died of cancer
it's a terrible story horrific yeah that
don't have pet chimps yeah so
helix
that's a nightmare but they've they've
gotten better with uh face transplants
so maybe she's yeah it is i mean the
most recent one that you saw in her
picture it was way better gotten better
that first one first
that doctor was like that's my first
time doing this you know i tried my best
but but it was rejected
in her face and everything like this is
a nightmare like it's it's a for her
sloppy there there's other face
transplants yeah your body just rejects
it you have to do it your face looks
like myself actually i'm actually a
little depressed thanks yeah i know
that's so sad
bringing it up
like you have to see it now
i hate seeing stuff like that it bothers
me so much all right all right well
oh not me there's a little get me out of
it
but then we're gonna go up so right now
this is a quick one it's like a spirit
flight
it's getting a little rocky but
eventually we'll get there so jack
morris who's the ex uh mlb player i
think he's in the hall of fame he this
is so stupid did you have you heard it i
heard it and as an asian how do you feel
i have different thoughts so i have
different thoughts so play it and then
let's give your thoughts all right so
let's all hear this real quick
this is shohei autonomous japanese
[Music]
be very very careful
and then watch
the third inning
has come to the plate and uh it's been
brought to my attention and i sincerely
apologize if i offended anybody
especially anybody in the asian
community
for working 20 years about pitching and
being careful to uh jose or
shohei ohtani
i did not intend for any offensive thing
and i apologize if i did
certainly respect and have the utmost
respect for this guy
he got fired dude
nowadays an apology means nothing it
just means you're guilty yeah why not he
said he would yeah yeah what are your
thoughts suspended indefinitely i don't
know if he was fired yet maybe there's
an update but so when i first heard it i
thought he was mimicking elmer fudd
that's what i thought i didn't think he
was actually mimicking a japanese yeah
be very very quiet
i would also say like that is pretty
much borderline i would be like you
shouldn't you should not say that right
now i will say asians have dealt with
that forever in this country until 15
minutes ago i got a guy
been doing play by play for 20 years and
then and then it was like he's just
sloppy at trying to be funny and then
the next at-bat he goes man i want to
apologize like that wasn't my intent at
all like well they probably got on the
phone with him and said hey but if he
was but if he was mimicking a japanese
voice he's not a comedian that's the
thing you guys can do it like kind of
messing around because you guys are
comedians i wouldn't do it no but we we
messed around here all the time you know
with you know yeah all the time yeah
which is fine you guys are comedians but
him doing that was kind of like i was
sort of like and i'm not even japanese
but it was a little weird should he lose
his junction 20. i always play i always
believe him also my thing is he
apologies oh he's like oh i [ __ ] up
that missed i missed the mark my bad i
wasn't trying to offend anybody then if
he wants to spend him for two weeks
that's fair there you go you know i feel
like people deserve chances
i think he apologized i think you make a
point by suspending him but i think to
him
if he was let's say he was that was his
first week there yeah he fired him like
dude we just we're not gonna put up with
it 20 years in the box play by play yeah
so like so all that gets erased can be
the stand-up citizen all that [ __ ] no i
don't believe he should i believe he
should just whatever punishment whatever
and then come back to you suspension
take a sensitivity or you know racial
trait whatever what's called so here's
my next question
just how to get just out of curiosity so
like
you know he went did that accent yeah i
don't think his intent was to you know
deliver batter or whatever but
what about like every time a british
person comes up to us
we tend to do that accident or like yeah
it's different so like the british
weren't uh discriminated yeah
discriminated against they didn't they
didn't go through the trials and
tribulations it's very different that
asians when you're asian when you're
asian there's no doubt i'm sure chin can
have tested it so the intent when people
do that
originally was to
um make fun of make fun of asians but do
you think about all the movies hollywood
did and like even yeah there's some
backgrounds these other networks that
allowed you know these agents to go on
and then now the summer like okay nope
that's off limits this guy's like what
right
we watched rush hour two the other day
the amount of uh races oh it's an asian
joke it was like this one it was a black
guy it was a black guy it's also a movie
too it's also a movie it's a little
different when it's real life which is
kind of yeah they they're bonded and
that's the point is he's you know he's
he's an older dude i'm sure he didn't
really get it he's an older dude jackie
chan beats the [ __ ] out of people and
you know and i do believe everyone
deserves chances so i don't believe he
should be fired he just learned from it
he already apologized so
honestly
my problem is we pick and choose like
billy eilish got in trouble for saying
uh making fun of i remember yes she did
yeah and she was like i didn't know i
was a young kid i was 18. yeah you know
i was caught on video she was like me
she was like saying something saying
something yeah and then she like made
fun of like the asian language and
everyone like gave her all this backlash
she was like yeah my bad those were
horrible things she said that we're like
okay she's young that's cool it's billy
island she's a sweetheart and i love
billy ellis she shouldn't be canceled
for that but then this guy does the same
thing like nope you're out dude look man
i think without reacting to it i agree
is that the fact that you can live your
whole life in an exemplary way and then
one thing erases you completely that's a
[ __ ] waiter that's yeah that's not
this guy had several cases against him
where he constantly does this and it's
like all right that makes sense and
obviously he's on air he's live he
doesn't think he's doing something
really bad he's just made a mistake
which i believe and that guy goes bad
what should they do with
he just be very very careful yeah don't
pitch to him he's such a good player
don't [ __ ] pitch them yeah you got to
be careful if you're going to be how do
you feel about the guy who got fired the
the basketball player basketball
i think color commentator for the
clippers who said all lives matter
that's insane
it's insane that we can't say all lives
matter yeah it's insane that you say all
lies mad and like well you're taking
away from the black lives matter okay
well let's look at black lives matter
the the founders of it have been fired
because they found out they were
stealing money and paying for houses all
around california you know what i'm
saying so you look at that movement and
what it represented it's our marxist
movement too correct well there's
there's there there is legitimate reason
to be
to be um
critical of the group in some aspects
right so of course and that doesn't mean
that you're racist of course it just
means you have some questions you have
questions yeah that's all it is
so someone got fired well if you're
saying all lives matter oh yeah
that is if you say it was at a
i guess he had a history like a lot of
the black clipper problems with him yeah
they were this was like the final
chariot he had a history of b they
according to them and i don't know the
situation i don't know the situation but
according to them they were like it's
about time for them they were like
yeah of course he would say it so i
don't know i don't know so my feeling is
there might have been a history of
something there right that's different
like you have a history of constantly
doing that yeah but if that's the first
strike then that and then he got fired
but you are being fired you are still
being fired for what you said that there
is and i know that there are certain
standards but when you when you sign up
to be to work for the clippers that
wasn't a standard that was that is an
interpretation of a racist comment that
i that that you could very much argue
was was actually the opposite which is i
care about all people
you know what i'm saying yeah and so so
that's a philosophy that he might have
so when you fire somebody for their
philosophy when you fire somebody for uh
you are making the assumption they
didn't say anything so you they didn't
say anything negative about anybody any
group that's where i have a problem with
it that's where i go oh that's very
that's a judgment call that is and
you're taking a guy who's been doing it
for 30 years on a high level and and
literally erasing him these things are
always wild to me because i always think
about
my biological father like you know did
17 years in prison wasn't in my life
you know we didn't reconnect until like
five years ago
but like
you know to just rule him out
you know
he you know he served he served his time
you know he did but he did bad things
and yeah it's very obvious this must be
for rehabilitation but also at the same
time but like 17 you know i could have
been the sun to be like nah [ __ ] that
you did this you did that you did this
you know and just ruled him out like
completely but
you know if i didn't just like
have a conversation with him and sit
down and come to an understanding and
like you know
and find out things that i you know
would have never known before you know
all of a sudden there's this thing
there's this room to grow but if i just
didn't then it kind of would you know
i think it would just leave no he didn't
you're talking about redemption you're
talking about people can change and
you're talking about people can make
mistakes and not be bad people and
you're that that's what we're talking
about well even even my stepfather like
i mean i don't have any ill will towards
it like if i see him i say what's up we
we talked like i mean it was a very
crazy point in time but also at the same
time like it's like that's not what it
is now and it's like the i feel like the
better
story or the better thing to tell is
it's like hey we this thing happened you
know he treated me like this and all of
a sudden we're good like i think that's
more of a beautiful story
to talk about than to be like
nah [ __ ] him like that he did this way
back in the day i don't know
right so
so a lot of times it is kind of hard for
me to like
understand this like
you know to to cancel someone out to
kick someone off the island that's it
they're not allowed back
you know whatever all that does make
things worse yeah exactly because i know
for me
you know when i when all the anger i had
towards my
stepfather and all the anger i had
towards my biological father for not
being there
[ __ ] i couldn't do any there was nothing
i could do there was no way for me to
like
move move forward with anything in my
life even even even though
i was out of that situation it wasn't in
my life
you know there was no way i could just
move forward so it was just like well
why don't i just [ __ ] why don't i try
this route why don't i try the route of
like hey that [ __ ] was wild or like
let's talk about it like you know where
were you at what like what happened to
you
you know what i mean now now there's
this like
dialogue and it's like understanding you
know i'm not saying i'm a great guy i'm
not trying to yeah i'm not trying to
like
you know
like
like yes he did crazy [ __ ] things but
at the same time
it's like well what's the better route
to take yeah you know i agree a hundred
percent man
that was a wise route
all right so it's going to take a little
bit more of a little tiny dive
and then i'll get him happy oh god no no
this is a little weird for me so there's
a steelers versus lions game and i'll
play the video for you first we don't
know exactly what happened with led up
to it right
i don't know why is this weird for you
is that asian no no this is a black guy
and a white woman
oh and he hits the because the white
woman slaps him oh yes and i just feel
like why are you slapping this dude but
we'll watch real quick
[Music]
so he doesn't go hit her
that's her boyfriend apparently then he
hits her there
i feel bad for the boyfriend too i don't
i don't know because his girl is he
should have caused her the first one
that girl hit him in the face [ __ ] that
she assaulted him i feel bad for this
guy and that [ __ ] we finally found again
worse here than brian
yeah
he slapped him you slapped him i thought
it would you there has to be some
repercussions
i'm saying i feel bad for the boyfriend
who that's his girlfriend or his wife
well he's he he wasn't doing anything
he's not involved hold on watch it was
bad because that girl like he didn't
want to start the fight the girl he
swung at the guy yeah because it's his
girl yeah look at rewind watch it again
i didn't see the swinging [ __ ] girl
yeah the girl is like noticing he's not
doing anything he doesn't do [ __ ] he
doesn't slap him oh no he he gets up
there and he's like he's just trying to
stop he's trying to stop it yeah yeah oh
there you go
he should have told her like yo sit down
that's part of the game yeah the girl is
the game the girl irritates me the most
she's the worst
she assaulted that guy so the girl
started that exactly and he didn't do
[ __ ] first of all she put her hands on
him that that that's number one then she
hit him in the [ __ ] face okay so
she's a piece of [ __ ] she started this
and she thought that that do so what
happens with a guy like that i can't hit
you because you're a girl you get away
with it but [ __ ]
boyfriend gets in there and does this
[ __ ] and then the terrible hair got
knocked out yeah so you know what and my
my thing is her boyfriend
should have seen that and her boyfriend
should have stopped that woman sure
he should have stopped her when she was
like when they were faced with character
i would have stopped that my girl was
doing that yeah i would say dude i'd be
like i'd be i'd be like you better sit
down because i'm the one who has to do
the fight yeah exactly don't do that my
girl's a hot head and they're women are
a hotheads but the problem is
you can't do that no you cannot do you
can't stop it and if she doesn't get a
guy i know anybody yeah but but also
anybody but also her hitting the guy
like
like guys should never hit women but at
the same time there has to be some
repercussions if he was defending he's
gonna play that game
if you're gonna play play stupid games
win stupid prizes that's what happened
that's why it's a tough one i just i
hate the fact that he has to hit the
girl but the girl is the one that [ __ ]
everything up in the first place she's
the one that's also like if you're a guy
and that girl's like trying to hit you
in the face and she's like trying to
fight you like what do you know what can
you do it's such a tricky situation and
it's not like he was trying to beat her
out
like like he hit her until like pointing
away yeah
what the situation what happened or how
this happened i don't know yeah it's
it's like yeah it'd be a different story
if he was literally trying to stomp her
the [ __ ] out
when you see the story chin scroll down
it's really not man's got on action with
a nasty brawl slapping the man in the
face now the vile view shows the woman
man some sort of argument you hear the
woman yelling something like shut up
shut up and get the [ __ ] out
apparently make contact she made contact
he says don't touch what's going on
before this what was going on we don't
have that much information on it yeah it
was a fight that was caught in the
middle because that guy could that maybe
that guy didn't have to be in her face i
would have walked away some girl's like
doing that i'm not having an argument oh
yeah yeah yeah i'm just not but that's
me it's currently i agree with you
started the whole thing yeah brian there
are ways to uh would you say yeah i'm
not getting this right i'm gonna stand
up and argue with you i'm some lady i
mean unless there's a very who knows did
she call him the n word like you know we
need more information yeah we don't yeah
we can't hit anything you just can't
yeah
what was he doing was he being loud was
he being dick i don't know and obviously
like i mean if his intentions weren't to
swing like he wasn't trying to put your
hands on someone's face like that if you
slap someone to me
you better be ready
to go whatever happens next like man or
woman you slap somebody punch somebody
in the face you have to realize there's
consequences oh you're gonna be fighting
yeah i would [ __ ] if i'm gonna hit
somebody but more people need to learn
that like more people need to learn like
this this what happens like so it's good
that these videos are out there and
there's girls i can fight i got beat up
by a girl once
my buddy was in an abusive relationship
with this woman and he was driving and i
was in the back seat and i never forgot
it and they were and he was they were
just having an argument it wasn't a
terrible argument and she just went she
just went
and kicked him and he just went
and he just went like i never forgot and
he went like this he goes
i kept driving and i was like
dude and then i go what the [ __ ] was
that and he goes that's every day and i
go well you gotta get the [ __ ] out of
that relationship did you ever meet
jacob jace and nianti's friend tasha do
you mean big black girl like super
athletic like real big black girl yeah
they went to kanto this is when they
found out jacob fight they went to a
concert i think drake yg and yeah yg and
these mexicans were sitting in front of
them but they were in her seats and she
was like hey you're like just sit over
there she's like well no those aren't my
seats if someone's gonna sit down there
and kick us out like we just want those
seats and the mexican guys go shut up
and sit down dinger
and she's like what the [ __ ] you call me
so she wanted to go at him and jay's
like no no and the guy says again and
then all hell breaks loose and then
jay out there [ __ ] rock bottom yeah
wow like both of them yeah
there's some cases where it's worth
fighting yeah some cases sometimes you i
mean if you have people you got to get
down with the get down about these
mexicans talking [ __ ] to jay and klopp
and tasha it's like jimmy burke jimmy
burke's there they get the same thing
guys this giant [ __ ] irish guy this
wide with a [ __ ]
tiny nose
a baby nose he had a
huge head
a baby nose and jimmy's always nice
jimmy goes excuse me you're in our seat
the guy goes nah
he goes what yes actually here i'm gonna
see and the guy goes like this he goes
shut the [ __ ] up
i like this guy's confidence and can't
do that to jimmy because he's with his
buddies and jimmy goes shut the [ __ ] up
that's amazing i could sit on your lap
how's that sound and that's how it
starts and next thing you know they're
[ __ ]
fighting all hell breaking all the hell
breaks because he's with his buddies and
they're all big jimmy's with all his big
buddies and
gosh it became an italian on irish long
island love it
what does she have to do what real quick
i i had a i have a friend who had
multiple girls that beat him up i'm not
even joking
at one time i was in a hotel with him
and you know like oh his girlfriend's
always beat him up yeah well two two for
sure uh there's a you know that thing
that's in front of a bed it's like it
looks like a little yeah
yeah
yeah he was on the bed and we're just
ready to go out and drink she lifted it
up and threw it on his head and i that's
the first time i really saw a girl a
girlfriend beating up
i dated a girl who would get drunk and
do that yeah yeah drunken my body
my buddy my buddy saw that my buddy at
saw
this girl
she whipped she took a boot
and and
whipped it so hard the heel of it at my
head she grabbed on the the
you know the what is the
[ __ ] back of it and swung it so hard
and it it made a it made a hole in the
plaster wall and i ducked i never i went
like two like that and went boom like
that and then she attacked my buddy saw
the he witnessed the whole [ __ ] thing
he goes dude i i am a witness to this
just so you know did you know she was
crazy no did you dump her after crazy
hot yeah you did it
with some [ __ ]
she was she was painfully crazy my joke
about how when you say you dated a nine
i'm like you don't know what a nine is
now careful now hold on revise that
because a nine is somebody you don't
know that well that you would move into
your house yep okay okay you don't know
that well that can hit you in the face
and you still are like
yeah that's gonna work yeah you put up
with some [ __ ] you put up with some [ __ ]
by getting hit i will not yeah what does
she get
all right so on the lighter note brock
lesnar he made his return
the reason why this is good is because
he lacks in the ufc i don't he looks so
different that's his new hairstyle check
that out oh it's kind of like mine
all right
well he's going to fake wrestle so
that's cool yeah well so yeah he does
definitely look different and this is
also a different look it looks pretty
sweet remember half thor
mountain
he looks to me it looks not that great
though it looks like weaker no we didn't
get shredded but he's lost right now
yeah yeah
he was giant before
good yeah he was so big well he got that
bell's palsy that thing honestly he does
and it comes in once in a while attack
or stroke or something like that he had
a stroke
he had a stroke in it when you're that
big [ __ ] up but it comes and goes so
some days it's fine yeah somebody's like
yeah okay
you're not the strongest man in the
world without doing other stuff of
course
and he's also just genetically gifted
he's humongous
so max kellerman is no longer with first
take dude how about stephen a smith why
hasn't i been trying for years to get
him off the show finally did it oh he
actually wanted him to ask
wow because he feels like max has like
this you know smartest man in the room
syndrome and he wanted more of a guy
that can debate and like have fun with
wow so they're just going to rotate
guests yeah they're going to take a
guess now steven smith's show once she
has been lately a little bit no
why
stuff yeah why it's a bunch of people
you don't know you know you don't like
when they go too extreme like they're
like we're not racist and then you go
too extreme that's what's going on in
espn
well
well he has other shows coming up so
he's good to go oh he's still he's yeah
with espn he's still with your spin he's
they're just putting
moving them to a different area exactly
what is this now oh so
i don't know how i feel about this i
used to i love them it's one of my
favorite cars it's my dream car i wanted
a kid so when they when i found the
release new countach hit up my car guy
yo dude give me on the list for a new
countach because you have to be on the
list they already sold out and he was
like
he was like yeah i'm on it they text
back goes dude they're like three point
something two million dollars
what oh boy they only made like a
hundred it looks so dope i don't know
how i feel but how looks it to me i feel
like it should look oh i look a little
better but i don't give away it's still
nice
i remember that countach has been around
since yeah 40 years or something there's
posters i've already collected posters
but
long time ago not 40.
they they released them in the 80s and
then they they stopped making them they
never think they might have released
well let's listen to it real quick this
is the first time since that release
that's why that's why it's such a oh
it's a new you don't like that so they
revised it the the look for me i don't
know i'm not crazy about that yeah i'm
not crazy about the look either crazy
crazy
great
i love it
they nailed it but that i remember that
with that much money for a lamborghini
get the [ __ ] out of here
1974
long time
so the first time they've made kutashi
in 21 years
yeah they only made a few of them and
they're like they're so expensive
bring bring up how much is the new
countach
there it is there it is right there
right there right below
2.64 oh they only made 112 of them and
that's just like market when you
actually buy it's probably
way better
inflation
yeah i was like oh i don't want that
anymore thank you for trying [ __ ]
they're sick though yes they are so
brendan you're right the head of only
found only fans says it's because of the
banks that's why now here i have a
friend who's close with only fans and he
says this is all cover so he's saying
the banks because
the banks play ball with uh
are you porn in like braziers so they
take their money oh so what only fans
was doing is they launched an app back
in october and they're trying to get
everybody to go toward towards their app
but their app could only work if they
didn't have porn on there but they got
such a backlash and nobody download the
app and such a failure there this is why
they're like oh our bat and now they're
saying you can't have porn on only fans
now they retracted their statement this
morning like we're just we're just
playing we just play we're just fine we
just so they were just saying because
everybody that on the platform oh we're
out there oh [ __ ] we don't have a
business
so now they're back though oh [ __ ] i saw
that this morning crazy so they they
they are not allowed to have an app
because it's porn
uh there's something with that like the
the the app wasn't gonna have porn on it
but now they can have and so them saying
the bank
but i'm saying the banks won't take
their money it's all just recover their
their app was a failure and they thought
everyone was going to ride with them and
and transfer over and go to the app and
not do porn but literally all the got
people like oh we're out but there's
some they didn't realize how many people
weren't going to follow got it and they
have massive fan bases and they
retracted their statement like just [ __ ]
with you guys you can do porn all right
just kidding uh just kidding no we can't
make money it's just too much money
we're out
damn well there you go
it's back to normal and tyga who's going
to start a porn subscription only fans
thing he's a [ __ ] because he was going
to start his own where he could have
porn but
definitely the market was open for it
with him and kylie jenner
no he's not with kyle
that would be travis scott you're a
racist i know no tiger was with kylie
jenner it was
a long time ago i'm sorry are you that's
like 2 000 yeah 15.
all right this is a ride you tried their
names are the same they're tiger travis
scott that's the same thing with tease
what is this this conor mcgregor's yacht
i just feel as though it's just not that
cool it looks awesome it's a lamborghini
it's just so small but he posted this
recently well that you can't call that a
yacht that's what i'm saying it's so
sick of mini cigarettes it's like a big
boat it's a cigarette it's pretty
[ __ ] sick though it looks awesome but
i mean look here's here's actually
actually looks fun
and it's super expensive but look how
small it is
that would freak me out right there a
little that's beautiful tilt
it's not a yacht but it's cool
yeah cool this is yacht bad camera work
but all right hold on what little nausea
calls out the lack of public outrage
over tony hawk's blood infused
skateboards
but it's not just it's not through nike
rapper would face backlash for satan's
shoes released back in march
points out a double standard of
tonight's limited edition skateboard
pain with his blood cells out in minutes
with little no criticism because
yeah it's not nike yeah it's his own
board it's his own board
for the uh like he could release like to
the outrage was because it was everyone
thought it was a nike
yeah
also while covets popping they release
it during the middle of coven
so he thinks it's a double standard no
dum-dum but it's it's actually tony
hawk's his own skateboard yeah else
everybody calm down yeah everybody come
down
also i don't just be gay
yeah
yourself dude sing your song you know
what i mean yeah shut up [ __ ] god
[ __ ] out
you listen to the rest of it not a bad
song i told you it was musically good
yeah i had to listen over and over
um it's not on spotify it's not it's not
gonna lie brian there was a lot of love
for uh for the song yeah a lot of love
people like the song shazam people like
the song yeah dude
i'm gonna i'm gonna do it
definitely release it i'll do a video
definitely do the whole thing i'll be
sick dude yeah they [ __ ] on my patreon
yeah hell yeah yeah all right so
christian told us about this our boy
shinigami remember he wants to go this
fight yeah where was this was this
details about no so he kept
like he kept texting me like random like
putting off the fight stick he's like
hey i'm not having a fight gotta move to
this i gotta move to this like he texts
me like three in the morning at random
times saying that his fights got moved
and then some someone who watches a
podcast actually sent me this clip
saying uh saying that shinigani got
waxed unfortunately and i'm pretty sure
that's why he's probably putting off the
fights because after the showing let's
see it alright i don't know if i can
actually air this but i'll play it for
you guys right now he was doing i think
he was doing well in the beginning it's
just yeah i
the guy he's fighting has some sort look
at his ears oh [ __ ] he looks tough
remember we live in a free country the
coven 19 icu average cost is about 60
000
so get vaccinated that's his sponsor
shout out shinagamika in the lab and of
course shout out rachel shout out rachel
that guy looks rough damn well he can
tell you some history with wrestling
because he just ties him up
a ref does not do math
at what point did you think he was doing
what kick the kick to the head like that
all right let's see got him with a hook
he's expanding and then he actually
reverses it which is good and then um
yes yes it does yeah i thought homie was
autistic
we still got love for him of course good
stuff that dude looked pretty rough
all right is that a chin that's it
guys let's do it um where are you at
brian
i'm in buffalo new york september 9 10
and 11 denver colorado september 23 25
comedy works chicago illinois improv
chicago
october 1.
and then um
uh yeah that's what that's what i got to
say uh on rockfin conspiracy social club
me and sam tripoli and uh patreon i got
some new stuff coming on uh patreon.com
uh the crew is uh in la jolla california
the comedy store california this
thursday friday saturday all shows
almost sold out we might add a late show
on thursday so get your tickets right
now thursday friday saturday this
thursday friday saturday then san jose
september 9th through the 11th san jose
improv then the big boy san antonio
texas bud light event center one show
september 24th one show september 25th
then i'm coming home september 30th
through october 2nd denver colorado get
your tickets at fatkz.com
or thickboy.com i'm excited to headline
my favorite club in california bria
improv
in all of california i love that club
have you done the comedy store yes oh
wow
what i can't say this one
no you can they said
your ultimate yeah but it's mine
what cops are you talking about what i
can't love have you done cops yet
you're doing it soon though right yeah
i'm doing uh cobb's uh september 8th
through the race and first i can't love
brandon no i'm just saying i didn't know
it was your favorite yeah i love that
yeah because yo yo i do that one a lot
yeah yeah
it's a good club
keep going doug i'm gonna choke you out
dude give give him your step give me
your 23 dates
keep going give him that tweet
anyways
improv august 26 tomorrow uh september
8th cops comedy club tickets f-a-t-k-z
all right kids love you love you